الاستعداد لمعركه هذا ما يقوم به الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب قبل جلسه
محاكمته المقرره الثلاثاء وفق محاميه من
المتوقع ان يسافر ترامب الى مدينه نيويورك
برفقه اعضاء من الخدمه السريه الامريكيه
من منزله في مارلاجو الاثنين ثم يخطط
للعوده الى فلوريدا بعد جلسه محاكمته حيث
سيخاطب انصاره بحسب محاميه ستحارب اي
اتهامات ضد الرئيس السابق بقوه وسيمثل
امام محكمه نيويورك لابلاغه بتهمه جنائيه
موجهه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لممثله
اباحيه بغيت شراء صمتها من المتوقع ان
يسلم نفسه للسلطات يوم الثلاثاء ومن
المقرر عقد جلسه استماع ظهرا في منهات ولن
تقيد يدا ترامب وبحسب محاميه التفاصيل
الاخرى للاستدعاء لا تزال غامضه بحكمه انه
امر غير مسبوق لا تزال تفاصيل التهم بما
في ذلك مهيتها وعددها طي الكتمان وفق
محاميه وسط نفيا بارتكابها من قبل ترامب
تقارير اعلاميه افادت بان ترامب سيواجهه
اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري
لدفع 130 الف دولار
في عام 2016 في محاوله لشراء صمتها بشان
علاقه جنسيه مزعومه وسائل اعلام امريكيه
ذكرت بان ترامب متهم بتزوير سجلات تجاريه
من الدرجه الاولى وهي جنايه بموجب القانون
الامريكي ومن المقرر تنظيم تجمع حاشد
لترامب مع النائبه الجمهوريه في مجلس
النواب مارجريت هيلرجرين ظهر الثلاثاء
بنيويورك داعيه ان صار ترامب للانضمام الى
احتجاج سلمي ضد لائحه الاتهام رش خياط
العربيه